un chroniqueur qui a été interviewé par
le magazine ici paris
c'est un magazine qui se trouve à paris
c'est juste ici et et il a fait une
petite annonce concernant sa
participation à tpm paix la saison
prochaine c'est bernard montiel
montbernard d'amour que j'aime bernard
montiel bernard montiel bernard mon ange
gardien
bernard on montrera pas si l'europe je
te montrerai sic et mon pote donc berne
bon temps à cause bernard montel donc
qui reste la saison prochaine avec nous
donc touche pas à mon poste à montbert
nous c'était bernard montiel en direct
du cap ferret bien entendu merci pour ce
témoignage je salue bernard pose la
question à savoir si les vieux
poursuivre l aventure avec vous et je
dis évidemment eu la chance de parler à
discuter et on a envie d'aller
évidemment de bon voilà bah moi ben
bravo voilà merci bernard d'avoir été
avec nous qu'on n'entend très mal
bernard
merci bernard d'avoir été là je te fais
de gros bisous monde et autant d'hommes
fait balmont jury donc je suis très
content que tu sois avec fulham et
possède et bien sûr tu seras toujours
partie de l'équipe
tu es notre famille on est à famille et
je serai toujours là voilà on t'aime il
est magnifique magnifique il est pas
beau petit que mou il est magnifique oui
jean michel maire je croyais qu'on
devait donner que des bonnes nouvelles
pour divertir les gens eh ben je me
donne une dans un instant vous verrez
vous ce genre sa mère sera dans tpm paix
le samedi et je vous adresse fred en
instance que tp sera du lundi au
vendredi merci voilà bernard mon chéri
entente entre image et on est très
contents qu'il soit là donc bernard
montiel sera là l'année prochaine
ce que je peux annoncer également aussi
valérie c'est que tu sera avec nous
l'année prochaine aussi
lassitude et moi je suis je suis avec
grand plaisir la vie tu raconteras là
bien sûr ben may jean-michel au civil
mais voilà benjamin laurence elle sera
bien sûr avec moi dans balances ton post
et sophie cost sera avec nous dans tpm
paie également l'année prochaine plus
souvent que cette année oui-oui adel et
ret réclamé par toutes les gens qu'elle
soit masculines féminines ou encore de
renault dit ni les longes mais peut-être
qu'il y aura un début d confie son c'est
plus sachez qu'à partir du 11 mai l on
sera pas donc voilà en configuration
taxe touche pas à mon poste
on va faire une émission avant voilà une
émission voilà d'humeur avec des images
bien sûr des rigolades des et on aura
chaque soir on va essayer de mettre en
place trois ou quatre chroniqueurs avec
moi bien sûr à distance 1 et on va
essayer de faire ça ça va être de 19
heures à 20 heures et à 20 heures
on vous proposera un jeu quand je vous
dis un jeu a priori on va là c est ça
peut changer à tout moment je me dis
vous proposera un jeu mais quand je vous
dis un jeu ça va être un gros jeu voilà
un gros jeu voilà je pense que vous
allez être très content voilà je peux
pas vous dire encore parce que c'est pas
encore fait c'est fait et je vous dis la
chaîne aussi ce matin j'ai eu gérald
brice viret jeu francs capitaux vincent
plus jeunes donc voilà alexandre israël
tous les patrons de la chaîne e
voilà il était aussi chaud pour
continuer à logbaba et ce soir chez ba
ba puisque l'émission je vous dis marche
très bien
voilà le il était pourri m'ont dit
pourquoi pas continuer jusqu'à fin mai
donc on continuera comme ça jusqu'à fin
mai ou bien si vraiment ça commence à
des confiné et qu'on a des garanties on
fera ce que je vous ai dis donc une
émission avec trois quatre chroniqueurs
de 19 heures à 20 heures et un très gros
jeu que vous connaissez de 20h à 21h pas
vous en verrez ça bien sûr vous verrez
ça voilà vers le 11 mai donc on vous
dira et vous verrez voilà ça peut vous
plaire ça peut vous plaît je vous dirais
je vous en dis pas plus mais je pense
que ça va vous plaire pour la rentrée
donc des pmp de retour bien entendu à la
rentrée forcément
sachez que tpm paix va encore repartir
pour je vous le dis au moins deux
trois saisons non le voilà avec moi
j'espère si vous voulez toujours de moi
les chroniqueurs bien entendu voilà donc
on va repartir pour deux à trois saisons
de tpm paix ce qui veut dire qu'on
arriverait souhaitant 13e saison qui
serait alors voilà on espère maintenant
ce qu'on veut c'est juste vous
accompagner tous les soirs on espère que
tout ça va s'arranger on espère qu'on va
pouvoir vous divertir et sachez qu'à la
rentrée il y aura énormément de
nouveautés aussi dans touche pas à mon
poste
on va garder l'équipe telle qu'elle est
il y aura également des petits nouveaux
dont un très beau gosse voilà alors deux
ans pascal à tout ce que je peux vous
dire voilà c'est tout ce que je peux
vous dire voilà les chéris je vous en
dira un peu plus tous les jours voilà
merci non j'ai dit un très beau gosse
jean-michel merci oui oui jean louis des
savants si je vous ai dit pas mal de
choses qu'on se ceux qui pensaient que
voilà tpm pc tu es allé à les reprendre
là on va par contre cette saison mais on
va reprendre
voilà en tout cas un truc avec les
chroniqueurs tout ça qui va normalement
vous plaire avec des conneries comme
vous aimez moi je vous dis et puis 71
pmp stp mp je vous dis pour au moins
deux voire trois saisons encore
voilà derrière donc voilà je vous dit
tout et je vous dirai toujours tous les
chéri e